hey there guys so trailer for the last
Jedi is out
don't start before him ready okay I've
got limited time today I've got a lot of
stuff going on I have held off watching
this thing until I could get home and
actually record my reaction to it so I'm
doing you know the more live reaction
thing we'll see that I think I have high
hopes for this I had you know really
good reactions to trailers from rogue
one and from the force awakens although
in those cases it was usually the second
or third trailers that were the ones
that really got me so if I'm a little
iffy on this one or if I'm not
completely don't take that as an
indication of lack of enthusiasm cuz
that's actually kind of what happened
the last couple times it was later
trailers that really sold me completely
and really got me pumped up but I'll
stop talking I'll watch we'll discuss
night sky of course oh not nice guy baby
oh okay Rock hey ray how you been
[Music]
ah okay the music will
that Island looks good with the sunset
the music will never stop just aw that's
chills
see helping her give birth
[Applause]
Oh Leia Oh dark
yeah okay I'd like that Leia was used as
the image for light that's nice feels
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a cool distance shot seeing her
flip that around
oh that's new okay this pit still in a
coma
and the Falcon truth
okay
Oh phasma's back
time for the joy tube to end
Oh
I am intrigued okay I gotta I'm gonna
start with the end it would be the end
it's time for the Jedi to end that um I
don't know if you can tell I was I was
preparing myself to like say with him
like return or come back any time for
the Jedi to it what does that even mean
I'm not okay you probably just saw like
like a fade-out my kid needed help with
with something so I'm back I'm trying
trying to keep this all together I would
have liked to have done anyone take
whatever parenting so um yeah those Oh
like the Jedi end that's just that ex
that's weird and that's like not at all
what I was expecting I immediately might
mind the wheels at my head are turning
and like the first thing I'm thinking is
like well like the the understanding of
like every fifth that we've run into our
at least that we've gotten a backstory
on I in the movies I'm not up on rebels
and Clone Wars and then and everything
else so if it varies there I'm sure
someone will tell me in the comments but
every sit that we've dealt with has been
some form of corrupted Jedi you know
obviously Anakin is a big one
you know Darth Tyranus you know
Christopher Lee he was a Jedi it's I
wonder if if meny Luke has come to the
conclusion that the the Jedi being the
source of that like if the Jedi weren't
there the Sith wouldn't spring out of
them if they didn't have that that
groundwork and then maybe it would be
better if we just just stopped
um I've no idea if that's the case I'm
done just riffing because that's that's
just a really intriguing um
note to end with the Jedi must end i I
don't know okay uh stuff other than that
we saw a bit more Poe I hope we get more
Poe in this one than we got here in
force awakens because I really like
Oscar Isaac and he was wonderful in
charismatic
oh we shall we get a fin he still passed
out that's that's odd those those
vehicles you know kicking up the red
dust that was that the color contrast
was cool I liked that like I said I
really liked that we get a shot of layup
for her light and you know with with
having lost Carrie Fisher that was that
just felt nice without being exploited
that was well-balanced Oh God there was
a shot that I'm pretty positive is the
same shot we got in Ray's vision of like
Luke you know collapsing next to our
tune you know putting his hand on our
too and there was fire like we got that
shot from another angle we got a like
from behind and we saw a new Jedi Temple
I'm gonna guess burning in the distance
that was nifty I'm like I think I
mentioned we got a really quick shot of
phasma hope she actually does something
anything because I'd like that actress
and the character looked cool and that
was one of the things that before for
Zoe's I'm like I wanna find out more
about that and I didn't so I'm hoping
we'll get a bit more payoff there it was
nice just hearing Luke and and this this
is gonna sound weird I I was nervous to
hear mark Hamill's voice good obviously
Mark Hamill I liked him as an actor I
needs an amazing voice actor he's got a
whole body of voice work but the thing
is his his voice worked for things like
the Joker and whatnot if you ever watch
clips of him doing he gets very mmm into
it and his normal speaking voice hasn't
I mean it's changed a bit it's gotten
older but he's still he's still got that
Luke a bit more kind of at a higher
softer register tone to it so I was
worried that it was either gonna be
weird seeing this more grizzled
character having that speaking voice or
that he was gonna do kind of the weird
body contortions that he doesn't when he
doesn't more put on voice it sounds like
they found a good balance that he found
a way to just kind of yeah add a bit of
gravel to his voice so that it has the
weight of years and tragedy that you
would want for what it seems like Luke
been through yeah have it still sound
like Luke
so like that that was a weird thing that
I was nervous about and that that fear
is now gone um I mean the main thing
that got yell gave me the chills is the
thing that has usually given me the
chills in this thing and that's the
music they I love just hearing this
music and seeing and attached to new
images it does it does give me the
tingles a little bit um I would say
overall this is something that I makes
me go yes yes I am still excited for
this it's not quite it's not quite like
the full that you know that I got would
like the second trailer - force awakens
or like the third trailer - rogue one
but I like I said ahead time I'm fine
with that for what I got I'm happy I'm
liking everything I'm seeing so far I am
intrigued by everything I'm seeing so
far I want to see what more we get out
of kylo Ren it seems like they seem to
be implying that his mask is like gone
because we see the mask shattered and
like the shot of him we got he doesn't
have the mask and I kind of liked the
mask um maybe I'm weird for that but
I'll just I I really want to see where
history goes cuz he's a character who
intrigues the hell out of me
I think that's about it on this that's
that that's good stuff good trailer me
likey so that'll be it I'll probably
turn this around and put it up today as
quickly as I can because I don't have I
said I don't I don't have a ton of free
time this weekend so I'm gonna get this
up calm so you can give it a look
obviously watch the trailer before you
watch me reacting to it but so what are
your thoughts on this thing whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter and council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
yes sweetie what is it
[Applause]